JANET CONRAD: So I think
that one of the hardest
things about Junior Lab is
that you're asking students
to do something that they
really have not done before.
They have not,
for the most part,
there are a few that
will have actually worked
as what we call UROPs,
undergraduate researchers.
But for the most part, most of
them have not been on their own
independently working in a lab,
where they have to figure out
what are their goals?
They have to figure out
what is the outcome that
is going to be good
enough, and so forth.
So there's a couple of
things that they learn
over the arc of the semester.
So one of them is how
to actually budget
your time so that you can
actually get a paper out.
Papers don't actually end.
They just stop.
You know, there reaches a
point where you're just like,
OK, I'm done.
And I'm going to stop.
And learning how to do
that is something that
just takes a lot of practice.
So there is that.
Then they're actually
also learning
a set of practical skills that
I definitely see evolution
on over the semester.
So especially with
error analysis,
they really improve
after lab one.
So they will have done the lab
0, which is the set of three.
And those, they are walked
through rather closely.
Then, they're on
their own on lab one,
and the errors analysis is
always really interesting.
And then we work on
that a little bit,
and you find that they get
much more sophisticated
about error analysis.
And the very best
ones start learning
all kinds of things
about error analysis
that are not just
the standard things.
I had a student
this semester who
was very excited
about learning what
called the delta chi squared
method, which is where you have
a model, and you
change your model
so it introduces some
extra parameters.
And you look at how
much of a change of chi
squared you get, given the
change of degrees of freedom
that you just introduced, to
see if that model is a better
model than the one
you had before.
And so they become much
more sophisticated,
and that kind of thing.
They also become much more
relaxed with the equipment.
They understand how
the equipment works.
Usually by a lab two,
somebody has broken something
and discovered that it didn't
really mean the world ended.
It was OK.
So they are more willing to
actually be more adventurous,
and just come in and set
things up, and so forth.
And also, they will have gotten
into the groove with their lab
partner.
And that's an
important point also.
Most of the time, they don't
seem to know their lab partner
before they get started.
And so figuring out what each
other's better skills are,
and how you play
them to advantage,
is an important
thing for them to do.
And it's important
in real life, too.
Most physicists work in
small collaborations, or even
big collaborations.
So being able to
work with somebody
and figure out how to
bring the best out of them
is a very important thing.